hello everybody hope they are good first
of all I hope that you had a nice
weekend that you could rest well and
that you charge your batteries because
this week I mean you can already start
to see that it's going to be quite a
volatile week and we have on Wednesday
the fomc meeting interest rate decision
and even though the market is clearly
expecting that the FED is going to pause
right here it's something that we've
mentioning
um in this Channel and on Twitter for
quite some time and that's something
that it's very priced in 98 of the
market believe so so if the research is
that basically the FED poses rates then
the market is not going to move okay
that's not where the volatility is going
to come from Bo we have the press
conference guys and the press
conferences of Jerome Powell lately
they've been quite boring he's been
avoiding some questions but remember
that some months ago
he was quite Brave and he was dropping
some Clues and the market was strongly
reacting from from those answers so
let's see what he does on Wednesday
let's see if he drops some Clues okay
that's why it's interesting to me now if
he drops on Clues I think that he's
going to be quite Hokies and I'm going
to explain to you why now in a minute
um I don't expect him to say that he's
done with the hike cycle okay I think
he's going to say basically as the
previous uh press conferences that they
remain data dependent that we'll see
what the data comes out like but yeah
it's possible that there are new hikes
okay basically I think he's gonna repeat
what he's been saying which is quite a
hawkish to be honest and in my opinion
the reason is this the oil chart okay
look at this look at the gasoline prices
we've been talking about this for quite
some time first of all in August
uh CPI came even higher than expected
but to be honest it wasn't because the
gasoline prices because they only went
up less than two percent you can see
here but now the problem is that in
September look what is going on he broke
out from this
um pretty much I would say nine months
resistance okay almost one year
resistance and it's going up exactly
from there
it's going up exactly
and nine percent up
that is crazy so CPI next month is going
to be fun
uh we should see a new spike in CPI and
of course the FED knows this
um I think he's gonna he's going to talk
about inflation quite Hokies so I'm
expecting fireworks yet okay
now if you notice the my in my chart I
was expecting to be honest a retest of
this uh previous resistance before going
to 93 dollars a barrel that that was our
next Target because we have he had a
level there but you can see how he
didn't even read this it keeps going up
that's a cause of concern for for the
fat and I think that I want to mention
this okay now if we go back to bitcoin
and that is uh where we want to make
some business right guys so in terms of
Swing trading I guess that most of you
read uh my Bitcoin soon the update that
I posted yesterday on Twitter this is
something that I've been doing for the
past year and a half so I think since
March and I've been doing every Sunday
without missing any single one okay
so um with these updates I try to
prepare ourselves ahead for the next
week and I was mentioning the idea that
Bitcoin was going to visit 27k and that
is the Keystone in the chart for me why
because in that zone does the mid-range
you can see here rain size range lows so
that's your mid range quality level in
the chart you can see here how he acts
you know pretty much as a support
resistance level
so that is where my focus is in the chat
at that mid-range also you have the
Confluence of the daily 50ma this purple
line over there so you can see how he
acted here as resistance uh here it was
acting resistance too then support but
it fails all right you can see that you
know all the way here was resistant
surprise to lower
so you can see how it's a key level in
the chart and I know that you can use
different EMAs but the 50ma it shows
that it's quite reliable a EMA and price
tends to react from that level
was okay first of all from here Spike up
and I was telling you yesterday I'm not
opening any limit orders when it short
limit orders at the mid-range okay wait
for price
to move
as you can see now why I said that okay
because if you open any any limit order
Sia in shorts they're already stopped
from your trade okay so if you are a
full-time Trader and you're gonna have
time in the screens then you know it's
better to watch for the reaction at that
level
okay now let's go back to the Daily time
frame first of all long a scenario idea
I wanted to see a spike up but I just
got that and then a retest of the
midterange and daily 50ma support if we
hold the level that's what I will be
opening longs to the range highs 28 300
but also notice how right above the rain
size so around this level 20 500 we have
so many
short Liquidations in the one month time
from Hublot capital okay so if I open
well if I'm given the opportunity the
price retraces and holds this level the
mid-range okay and it gives me the
opportunity to open lungs then I'm gonna
close some at this zero line and then
also
some of the position here right above
the range size at those liquidations
okay because price tends to go to heat
those retail liquidations positions all
right so that's the long idea and then
of course you know if you can get a
backup of the rain size you have the
chance to go and retrace this liquidity
pool all the way there okay because yes
I mean this is liquid pool
that is when I get retrace sooner or
later the thing is that you know
sometimes they can take months to get to
get retraceable once you're above the
mid range that is going to be naturally
your next Target okay 31 500. right so
uh but yeah if we play the range that's
what I'm watching okay I would like to
see a retrace test this level of support
and that is when you can open along
towards the range highs that's the long
setup now in regards to the short
essenerio
then this should probably then get
triggered on Wednesday if your own power
is really Hokies and in that premise you
could say that this move is a false move
one is false move okay so for that what
you would like to see is that this
confirms as a deviation above the mid
range so on Wednesday then you would
like to see a drop again below this
level below the mid range and below the
daily 50ma test your resistance and that
is when you can open shorts
towards the range loads okay that is how
I'm playing this in terms of Swing
trading so so far regarding swinging
trades I'm flat I'm not in any positions
I'm waiting to see what happens okay do
we get the retest here a support I open
long do we wait until Wednesday and
price gets below this level tester
resistance than an opening shorts and
that is how a Trader has to trade okay
it has to react to price it's a game of
probabilities so if you set up you mean
sort limit orders
just because what happened here
was a test of the daily 50ma and then a
drop
then let me tell you something
it's trading setup is unique
it's moment it's Unique regards trading
so you can open a short here
are the daily 50ma just because here
it got tested resistance and then it
dropped okay because this moment here is
unique all right because here for
example you have the momentum here then
the race Trace moving continuation is
different than just uh and for example
what happened here was the news of the
ETF and grayscale okay and that is why
price is spiked up towards this level
okay and then got rejected
so remember that please each moment in
trading is unique
you don't have the same setup twice and
it's a game of royalties okay so that
being said how can we trade today's New
York session well this is for the day
trader so
uh the first thing is that there is no
way I'm logging this okay there is no
way I'm longing this it's extremely
overextended look how many red counters
okay also these green candles they are
huge so the chart is clearly extended
and in terms of day trading or scalps
when this happens you should not chase
the momentum you should not Chase all
these candles okay it's more profitable
to wait
for high probability trade that could
indicate a reversal in lower time frame
so for that what I would like to see
is uh for first of all New York opens in
one hour but so far what I've been
seeing is that Asia has pumped London
has pumped so let's see one New York
those okay you cannot say that based on
the trading sessions that you guys know
what it is is that one trading system
manipulates price up or down so it pumps
or looms the other one holds and that
didn't happen so then New York and
reverse okay that can't happen today
because nobody
right both Asia and London pooped right
so you cannot determine that New York is
going to dump so that's why you have to
be careful here what I'm going to do is
go into the 15 minutes time frame
15 minutes
50ma it's at 26 900 so far away from the
current price and if you check
previously you can see that price tends
to test you all the time look this is
quite similar to my it might have
happened here
okay it's very similar but then price
goes back to the 50ma all the time you
can see it also here okay or here you
see that all the time guys all right so
that could be what we would see today
now
I have probably trade in my opinion to
go short would be to see some spikes up
in the New York session by Price not
progressing any further up that is well
maybe you could even see a stop hunt
gets back inside this level
and that's when you can open a short
again towards uh the daily 50ma or the
mid-range okay so that is for example in
a scenario that you could be playing
okay and again it's not Financial advice
I'm just telling you my plans for today
if I want to enter short I don't enter
short in the first red candle because if
you enter a short here look what
happened okay you already stopped or
you're underwater any of them instead
wait for a high probability setup to
develop but for example to see some
spikes here okay well first of all wait
for the linear session to start and then
decide but this is an interview here
some spikes here some weeks to the
upside the price not progressing any
further that could give you an
indication the price has lost a momentum
momentum is over and then it's ready to
roll over
all right so thus is uh what I'm think
but yes do I expect the New York
retraces today I mean naturally look at
this chart
you mean is is asking for a retrace
okay it's as simple as that you just
have to be careful with what you're
doing three is that's all but
um that's what I'm expecting there is no
way I'm longing this am I long
if we go to the mid-range because you
want to notice how the daily 50ma is
also there so you have that Confluence
what could be a potential support so if
we drop here
and we consolidate above support that is
telling you okay that's a push up
retrace continuation to the upside okay
and you go to the range size so that is
what you want to Long here okay that's
the song where you want to long this is
not as soon where you're going too long
it's simple it's as simple as that guys
that's how I'm saying okay now let's go
to High block capital I hope that that
was clear guys uh no much to say uh more
you can see also how these two liquidity
pools here go retrace
perfect this week also getting retrace
there you see
so uh price could at any time drop again
towards the mid-range so try not to
formal because that's never a good idea
okay but I also don't try to cut knives
or in this case don't try to cut stops
because um
you can get or underwater for several
days and then you have to keep adding
margin to your position so you don't get
liquidated
um that's amazing guys that's not how
you want to trade it's as simple as just
try to pick high probability trades
in order to become more profitable it's
as simple as that it's all about
efficiency if you only chose high
probability trades
you would you could be making more money
or losing less money
it's as simple as that guys okay so that
is uh what you have to think
in terms of probabilities so only
focusing high probability trades and
being neutral just because price is
going up you'll need to chase green
candles or you don't need to try to cut
stops wait for that setup to develop
okay it's as simple as that for example
what I've been telling you 15 minutes
time frame if you seek weeks here to the
upside
the price not progressing any further
within the New York session that is
telling you that this momentum here it's
venison price drops and here you have
about Simpson pattern
okay that's Bart say hello
anyway guys let's go now to have your
Capital uh let's see what the liquidity
is really okay one hablo Capital let's
see the Delta first massive Spike there
because over the weekend with this
boring price action then Traders tend to
close their position so at the end the
Delta goes to zero you can see there on
the weekend and now we just Spike from
zero to six billion dollars worth of
long liquidations all right you can see
here also that you got pretty much uh
it's not a big ratio it's kind of like
pair every short you have two Longs open
so it's not it's not a clear short based
only this
um the liquidation level so let's go to
the liquidation seat Maps to see if we
can extract some more information
seven days time frame
what I see here
is that we hit these liquidations at 27
000.
uh we also have some here 27 500. you
can see but of course
you have some to the downside
okay
but you have to think that just because
this heat map is telling you that 25 700
is yellow
it doesn't mean that price is going to
go directly away look at the chart okay
you're right now above the mid range are
above the daily 50 May so
if you are shorting
above support right now
it's not a good idea at least wait for
that mid-range to get lost once you lost
once you lose that mid-range and the
daily 50ma again then you can short
towards this direction ball for now just
because it's yellow
don't aim for this uh Stone in the chat
it doesn't make any sense
one month time frame let's see what is
going on here
okay let's go all this soon this
liquidations get hit
these liquidations are slowly building
up still but you got here 28 500 this is
what I was mentioning earlier a lot of
liquidations also are twenty thousand
three hundred this is basically the rain
size so again if price continue pushing
higher that is going to be the next
Target naturally okay and in the three
months time frame
if you can check this
you can see how the liquidity here
it's huge okay again take these numbers
with a pinch of salt because I've seen
this with I've said this before high
block Capital doesn't reduce the
liquidations because they don't know
when the Traders are closing positions
so what they only do is to either
increase the positions or keep them the
same that's why uh you see this uh
either getting brighter or staying the
same you don't see that uh getting less
bright okay
liquidity
below uh the range lows now
this three months time frame
we could even take a still some months
to get here to this to this Zone if we
do okay and that means that as we are
right now in our range price can rent
here like this boom boom boom plain ping
pong or tennis
and the Liquid Agency are going to
increase but they can wait okay so there
is no a Rouge to wait for these prices
to get hit that's what I was telling you
when we hit the range lows that's what
the short that we called from the range
highs of the previous range are 31 400
we open a short there remember guys
because this pump here was a deviation
then you get back inside this range
tested a resistance comes well
consolidating on the resistance that is
key we open shorts there and I was
mentioning this idea for a week or so
that's where I open
that is where I opened the short but I
know that some of you also did
and then when we hit this range lows of
a previous range that's when we close
the position of 25k all right so
um there is no rules for this Zone to
get hit because this is high time frame
so don't make that mistake that because
this zone is yellow you have that yellow
bar price is going to get there because
that is not how you read this chart okay
you also have to use the trading view
chart and a bit of logic to understand
the price can take several months until
we get there
all right so that is pretty much
um what I see
what's the mid-range that is where you
can do business
either to go long if we get the rate as
a support or to go short if on Wednesday
we will start level and I say Wednesday
because when it's a catalyst to see a
big retrace in my opinion and that could
be on Wednesday if you're on power is
Hokies okay so from Wednesday we lose
the mid range on The Daily 50ma again
that is when you can go short and you
can aim again for the range loss at 25
300 I think it is so anything else
you have to focus on day trading okay
you have to know what type of Trader you
are and you have to know what time frame
to use for your trade so
that is my swing trades idea they are
based on the reaction of of the price in
the mid-range and then for short term or
day trading that's for example what I'm
saying what I'm entering your uh right
now
wait
to say for example some weeks of The
Upside in the New York session but
pricing operation any further that is
where I'll be opening up short again to
the 15 minutes time frame 50ma for
example or you can also aim for them at
range okay so those are the types of
plates that you have to differentiate
okay swing trades versus day trades I
hope that was clear guys click save
because uh
we've started this week with a lot of
action and I have a feeling that it's
only the beginning so thank you so much
for watching guys
and I'll see you soon